c'est n'importe quoi moi j'aime bien
quand il ya des nouveaux emoji mais que
ça lance un message je ne vois pas où
est le message en fait à ce moment mais
on met des on va mettre des femmes avec
des kiki on va mettre les des hommes je
comprends pas je vois pas ce message
s'est du coup ça c'est toujours les
trucs pour rien en fait moi j'aime bien
d'être démago mais qui sert vraiment à
quelque chose des noms j'ai même pas
envie de leur donner la parole je vais
faire je vais faire parce que je donne
la parole à tout le monde dans mon
émission donc géraldine je vais demander
aujourd'hui parce que la bouche je
risque d m'énerver la mairie comprends
qu'il y ait effectivement ça peut
paraître anecdotique et dérisoire de la
même manière qu'il ya un siècle vous
pouvez considérer pendant que le mariage
pour tous ou l'avortement s'étaient
c'était une avancée de la société qui
paraissait complètement dingue sauf que
là aujourd'hui même si ça concerne une
extrême minorité il ya des hommes qui
peuvent tomber enceinte mais un mec qui
a quitté jeunes tranchant en fait au nom
non mais là mais des hommes qui ont
conservé leurs ovaires et les rites et
russe non mais tu peux trouver que c'est
ridicule mais y en a ça existe
concrètement ça existe alors voilà et
comme c'est aujourd'hui les émaux j-100
inventé par ou en tout cas sont décidés
par apple et par la silicon valley
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la grande
salle culture à mort locaux qu'ils monde
est construite ou pas forcément ça ça va
danser dans cette mouvance en valeur la
silicon valley vous
avez projet la tête de l'eau alors voilà
kaka qui revient de la vallée de dan ar
mais c'est du délire là où il tombe pas
enceinte et puis à l'avortement et le
mariage pour tous c'est ça existe
l'avortement comme ça ça peut exister un
meilleur passant par amis maintenant ça
existe meriem il me paraît sain et
peut-être que dans laissez le parler non
moi je
l'entends oui on en reparlera donc
content tiens dans 30 ans avec nous non
mais justement je suis contente d'être
vieille et deux parce que ce monde va
pas du tout je suis désolé mais
c'est plus possible qu'en soit la raison
mais je manifeste jamais descendre dans
la rue faux arrêt pour sa
raison de la neige a envahi tout le
monde quoi alors après on passe pour des
vieux cons au plafond n'ose pas on n'ose
même pas le dire c'est presque une
pointe de domination dire que je suis
désolé alors raconté super g que j'adore
vont amener gilles super relou
le respect que j'ai pour vous vous
feriez mieux de vous taire
complètement raison répondre oui c'est
être rétrogradé
direct avec tact à coiffure des machines
modernes
enfin emoji inclusif enfin la
reconnaissance qu'il n'y a plus de genre
il ne faut plus de genre aujourd'hui
nous sommes tous non genre et
[Musique]
chiba de venir donc je le sens arriver
un moment vraiment l'être il faut
contacter pas méconnu tant belge de l'ue
étaient encore non mais tu es devenu
complètement taré mais pourquoi pourquoi
les selles des maux de tête à réparer
mais factuel te supportent encore
fait et monique nommé gilles wii était
pas au courant de la technologie tapas
portable je sais papa 1,3310 peut-être
mais il ya quelques son portable dans
son zen ce qui est très pratique sur les
iphone ce que tu peux créer ton est
maudit les bas tu te crées ton et mode y
ai vécu le mqm dans le truc mais
celui-ci honteux l'impôt il reste une
minute sur ce sujet matthieu vous rendez
compte de l'importance des états unis
aujourd'hui il était bien sûr et
quelques scènes insupportables
américain aujourd'hui ça sur un sport tu
veux mais comme ces fichiers tu choisis
l'année que tu as dit roland alors tu
peux être non j'oubliais l3 gens non
j'en riais l'homo guerre qui fait plus
tu fais ce que tu veux tu que des cas
tout en papotant passeport et que c'est
parce que tu es moi un passeport déjà il
ya trois cases et la troisième temps je
ne sais pas de se prendre ça déclenche
chez sas avait des états unis en
permanence il met une culture et je me
suis assurée c ou c à vous je m'occupe
[Applaudissements]